what do you think the main reason is
that women cheat for like the people
that you see
oh is there like a like a particular
pattern of why they're doing it
I would say it's usually based on their
personality you know if you have a woman
that is more disagreeable and more open
to new experiences uh that's a dangerous
combination for a man to have you know
some some women just like variety right
and men don't normally think about it in
in those terms because men want to think
about love and this and that but men
often forget that that women are humans
like they're just like us right some men
are not fit for example for the
institution of marriage because they
love variety way too much and